i'm 20 years old and i'm addicted to
drinking gasoline eating bugs rescuing
food from dumpsters eating sand
people have some strange addictions and
actually made a show about it and while
you may be tempted to laugh hear me out
at my points first before going to judge
b my name is nathaniel i'm 27 years old
and i'm in a serious relationship with
my car
[Music]
interesting
good morning baby
it's a pretty car i'm not gonna lie i'm
digging the color
i say it was love at first sight his
body and then his interior and
everything just together just seemed to
fit and i just felt an instant
connection
[Music]
you know this objectophilia seems like
it runs in a similar pattern as animism
where someone believes that uh inanimate
object has a spirit that uh is living on
and that's why they fall in love with it
nathaniel's relationship with chase goes
beyond dates and presents
we have our times when we get sexual
does that feel good there has been some
research that has showed a sexual
gratification or objectification of an
added object does sometimes run in a
similar course also with autism so i
don't know if autism was in fact
diagnosed in this case i'm 19 years old
and i'm addicted to eating sand
sand
okay i just love the crunch
that's not good for the teeth there's a
condition known as pica where
individuals actually crave foods like
sand soil paint even metal objects and
there are treatments for it bria is so
dependent on that satisfying crunch she
turns to nail files when her sand supply
runs low it has like sandpaper on it
that gives me the same crunch
so i
put it like on the back of my teeth
and just like this essentially you're
sanding down your teeth when you grind
them down with that uh very abrasive
surface of the sandpaper you're actually
doing serious damage to it i wouldn't be
surprised if she's gonna need dentures
or like implants very early on in her
life unless this gets addressed i'm 20
years old and i'm addicted to drinking
gasoline
gasoline is toxic and i'm not just
saying drinking it inhaling it getting
it on your skin in fact individuals who
work surrounding gasoline vapor have
higher rates of certain illnesses animal
studies have showed like kidney liver
disease from extended exposure to
gasoline vapors i can't go a day without
it
like i crave it i
need it
i'll wake up go to the washroom and
drink the gas this is super dangerous
because of a compound called
hydrocarbons found within gasoline which
actually act as a central nervous system
depressant you can almost feel like
you're drunk off of it but the danger
that it causes to your gi tract your
vital organs outweigh any potential
benefit of consuming it stanley might be
31 years old
but for the past 18 years he has gone to
remarkable lengths to remain young at
heart
very young
okay i understand if you're watching at
home and you're quick to judge this
gentleman and say
wow this is clearly a disorder
wait the way we decide in medicine in
healthcare whether or not something is a
disorder is based on the patient's own
life if the patient is not having an
issue maintaining a job maintaining
healthy social connections maintaining a
relationship if all these major
developmental aspects of life are normal
this is not a disorder we have to be
very careful with our definitions here
and he doesn't just talk the baby talk
he dedicates eight hours a day
role-playing as a toddler that's an
important fact to hear because if you
have to dedicate eight hours of the day
to do this can you maintain a job can
you maintain social connections it's a
feeling of being safe something i didn't
have when i was growing up
and being an adult baby became my way of
coping with the world and my own
problems humans are great at finding
unique coping mechanisms this works for
him something else may work for you just
we have to make the decision
together with a patient and a doctor
whether or not that coping mechanism is
a appropriate for who you are and b
whether or not it is distracting or
detracting from your everyday life
stanley has even tried baby formula but
like every other toddler he can be
extremely selective i mean baby food
like that is basically just like mashed
up fruits so it's not like the end of
the world eating that but like baby
formula breast milk all that really high
fat content you really have to be
careful i don't have any broken bones
but i'm addicted to putting orthopedic
cast on my body
what i'm perfectly fine perfectly
healthy i like the feeling of the chaos
around me just wear a compression sleeve
i've done like two full arm casts two
full leg casts i've done two full length
cast and an arm cast i put on so many
different casts it's ridiculous he just
wants to be cuddled i get it i need that
too sometimes i just don't go all the
way to getting a cast on but like
sometimes i do that with a blanket and
then i lay on top of it so i feel like i
can't get out it's like being swaddled i
was 12 years old i broke my arm
rollerblading and i got my first cast i
got a lot of attention with a cast on
and it's just kind of been an ongoing
process ever since then that is a
medical diagnosis actually people who
feign illness in order to get attention
or sympathy that needs to be obviously
diagnosed and addressed if that's the
case my name is dave gracer and i'm
obsessed with eating bugs
initial
impression of mine is this might not be
so bad because bugs are actually kind of
nutritious he has eaten more than 5 000
bugs over the past 11 years does he keep
track of the numbers of bugs that's
interesting when it comes to getting
bugs you got to kill them and there's a
variety of ways doing that i prefer
freezing them because you go to sleep so
i think it's the most humane way you
don't just go to sleep you're viciously
cold and then you go to sleep it's not
like he's giving them a paralytic agent
to knock them out and then freezing them
david's interest in eating insects just
kept getting bigger grasshopper
grasshopper grasshopper bigger fly pupa
cicada bigger scorpion tastes kind of
like this weird plastic and you enjoy
eating weird plastic like i want to know
his explanation i have follow-up
questions i started going into the woods
and getting my own bugs and i think the
first ones i found was a whole log full
of carpenter ants and i tried those ants
are very rich in protein ants
grasshoppers like grasshoppers almost
have the same amount of protein per
hundred grams as red meat does when he
wants something more exotic he goes to
his personal supermarket the pet store
today he is picking up a specially
ordered bug he has never encountered
that that is a monster i will eat a
monster
you want to make sure that you're
thinking about toxins that the bug has
inside of them the bacteria that's on
the bugs you also want to think about
anti-nutrients that are actually meant
to discourage predators from eating them
by not allowing us to withdraw the
protein from the foods and it actually
stops the protein absorption inside our
bodies the vietnamese centipede is the
only species of centipede to have ever
killed a human being
right in the oil
i'll season him again just real quick
with salt and pepper
how does he know to season it with salt
and pepper how does he know those
flavors go together if he's never eaten
it before that's just like throwing salt
on an already potentially salty food and
be like the heat not only cooks the
insect it also breaks down the poisonous
venom there you go take a peek and see
what we've done today for you dave
oh my god
it's still got the very much the look of
the beast the luck of the beast but
there's so much muscle tissue
i feel like i was about to throw up
i understand why you say that this
concept isn't that out there for me
because by eating more insects we can
place less strain on our land have
highly highly nutritious and
protein-rich foods brought to our diet
especially in areas where we don't have
farming abilities i've actually tasted
grasshopper before not too shabby we're
the strongest family in the world
nick cali dylan
and jessica best you can do it train
their bodies up to 240 hours each week
that's a lot of hours of training while
some pediatricians warn against weight
training for kids eleven-year-old dylan
routinely deadlifts 130 pounds i do like
working out it's like my coffee in the
morning if i don't do it i don't feel
right i love that this kid is so mature
i'm initially looking at this 11 years
old
is probably on the earlier side of
starting to lift heavy weights the idea
is that you risk injury when you have
non-fully formed muscles tendons
ligaments bones and start lifting heavy
weights it can be done safely you just
need to be very careful and monitored by
a professional kids like below the age
of seven shouldn't be doing
weightlifting at all starting at age
seven you could start incorporating
strength training that's good but just
not with heavy weights oh my gosh jj
experts recommend children her age
trained with one pound weights
but she can lift
100 pounds that's probably not ideal
that being said i doubt that this was
going to do any real damage to her
growth plates that was kind of
a myth that we had published by the
american academy of pediatrics in 1983
where we thought that could happen it
was a potential risk and as time went on
we saw that happen less and less
especially with proper training dylan
and jessica consume nearly twice the
recommended calories for their age while
we do give recommendations on caloric
intake
that is a wide-ranging recommendation
needs to be individualized so for
children that are highly active like
them and we see how their weight and
their bmi is trending we can make
different changes to their diets and to
the recommendations so the fact that
they're eating a lot more than an
average child isn't that wild to me
because they're burning a lot of
calories by doing all these workouts
several times a day
hi i'm kelly athena and i'm obsessed
with rescuing food from dumpsters
ah i'm with it we waste so much food in
this country while other countries
starve i don't think this is a terrible
idea i just hope they're doing it safely
the average american household spends
over 500 dollars a month on groceries
and we oftentimes spend money on
groceries that look the prettiest and
waste the food that may not look pretty
but is just as nutritious just as tasty
everything i have in my fridge
i got from the dumpster
apples cucumbers pickles condiments
grapes cantaloupe here's some soy milk i
had and it it even expired more than a
month ago sometimes it's a full on
expiration date but you really need to
understand what that date is for because
that date could be like for ideal
freshness or for ideal taste it still
might be calorically nutritionally
valuable i'm not afraid to eat right out
of the dumpster if it's if it's good
stuff there's this peach if i peel it
that'll be pretty safe to eat
if i eat out at a restaurant i don't
know who's preparing that food back
there i don't know if i'm a fan of that
logic you don't know who's preparing the
food at least it's cooked here you're
getting food that's been living in a
dumpster what if a raccoon pooped on it
b is spicing up the four-month-old
dumpster pizza with cheese two weeks
past its expiration date over ripe
tomatoes kelly found a week ago maybe a
little diced fennel fennel found at the
bottom of a trash bin just this morning
it's a fresh dumpster fennel and frozen
chicken chicken if it was even not
frozen for a short period of time
bacteria can start proliferating on it
especially if it wasn't stored or
prepared properly oh man i've had a
personal close friend of mine who eats
thoroughly cooked foods eat out at a
restaurant get an infection from one of
those foods and then develop an abscess
which is a pocket of infection inside
his brain and he still has neurologic
effects as a result of that so
this isn't like totally benign i also
reviewed family by the time living life
as an 800 pound person click here to
check that out as always stay happy and
healthy